speaking of another anime that has like
really
unique voice actors in their cast are
you guys excited for eden
yeah i am actually that is like one that
i saw
i saw little bits and pieces i mean i
knew of it because
yeah a boy care
it's one of those things that wasn't
really on my radar massively it was just
like i know kevin's doing the soundtrack
yeah i'm probably gonna watch so i could
be like
great job kevin yeah i wasn't excited
until i saw the clips that we were shown
which is by the time this podcast comes
out the entire series would have already
been released right
but from the clips that we were shown i
was genuinely like surprised how excited
for this i was i wasn't that excited
before
because i didn't really know what it was
about or how you know good it was going
to be
all i know were the names involved and
what stood out to me was of course
kevin doing the soundtrack so of course
i was always going to watch it but then
the cast list got released and people
like david tennant are in there yeah
neil patrick harris yeah i was like what
is going on
i'm sorry my favorite movie my favorite
yeah it looks really good i mean the
clips we saw as well the animation
looked really [ __ ] good yeah like the
way they matched uh the 3d with the
amazing 2d backgrounds [ __ ] amazing
and again the music we should [ __ ]
bang it
yeah yeah i don't know what else to say
i kind of want to just wait till i watch
it i don't get too hyped for it just
in case okay but it looked good it's
literally out
this week so yeah i feel like it's going
to be a 7 out of 10 for me
really i feel i get that maybe maybe i
get that it depends because it depends
if it's like how it's going to play out
whether it's going to be one long series
because it's a four episode series
so is it going to be only four episodes
or is it going to be like kind of like a
movie mini series kind of thing that's
what i want to know
i'm hoping it [ __ ] me up you know makes
me very emotional yeah but i have a
feeling in a play of really safe it's
going to be quite like a
safe story yeah i i just i just got that
vibe from the clips we watched
so we'll see i got that i might be
pleasantly surprised
i got that vibes that i was going to
fuel things by the end of it and
yeah the same way i did in the end of
monsters inc you know
i feel like that's what are you talking
about well when they finally you know
they got rid of randall then
they're rascals and they say goodbye to
blue yeah goodbye very much
is a great act that's a terrible example
yeah
i was just like if it's anything like
monsters saying i'm going to be happy as
[ __ ] i'm only thinking of great movies
right now but
the incredibles are like no that's
fantastic
like i feel like they've i feel like
these are the movies that have just been
memes so much that you forget
they're actually pretty good [ __ ]
movies right why is it so hard to think
of like some parts like the ending of
mulan
ii straight to dvd i did not even watch
it i haven't watched it either i just
i don't even know there was a new
lantern there's a moonlight